hello and welcome to another episode of
not too deep i'm your host
grace helbig very excited to have
the one and only miss peppermint with us
on this episode
you might know her from rupaul's drag
race you might have seen her on broadway
in head over heels and you will
definitely be hearing her
on her upcoming album a girl like me
letters to my lovers
oh she is just the absolute sweetest
smartest most beautiful
human being and we talk about everything
we talk about
what it was like behind the scenes at
rupaul's drag race uh
how a major relationship and breakup
inspired
her upcoming album and she gives some
really wonderful advice and thoughts
about how to approach the upcoming
election which is very important so
please
enjoy this wonderful episode of not too
deep with miss peppermint
[Music]
miss peppermint i am so excited
to have you and to talk to you about all
of um the exciting things happening
for you in the the strangest of times
but first of all thank you so much for
being here
hello it's so good to be with you it's
been a whole year
i know we got to chat for this series
called ladies first that was for
facebook and it was really really
wonderful and you were such
a champion for coming like from a plane
to set
doing the whole thing like i was just so
i think myself and everyone on that crew
just watched in all of you the entire
time we're like
this is a professional she is lovely and
she is so
oh it's so great so thanks for coming
back and chatting
yes mama now you're up to a billion
things
i i have to we're gonna get into the
music
and to all of that but let's first start
with let's start with drag rates let's
start with
um all of the conversations i'm sure
you've had 12 000 times about 12 000
things
but uh season nine
i wanna know um i wanna know
what how do you describe if you remember
your audition tape for season nine
oh it was um i mean i've done three of
them
as an audition for season six seven
seven eight and nine okay and um
and they were they were all kind of the
same
um but they were they were agonizing
because i remember
um i mean i i haven't even looked at
them since then
oh i'm sure yeah
but i i i mean i was full of energy
because i was excited and trying to like
really turn it on for the camera
but i just remember like being like oh
this is miserable like i don't i
it was like the last thing in the world
i wanted to do sure
i just was not i think i was
all the way over it in the last one
really i was like i don't give a hell
whether i get on the show or not
yeah i'm gonna do it and maybe i will
maybe i won't
and that's the one that they picked
that's the energy
yeah as soon as you have that energy if
you don't need them they need you
yeah then you get it now i was just
talking with evie
oddly the other week uh who's a guest
and she was telling us about
the bts of of the the production side of
things and how
she in her hotel room watched a lot of
naked and afraid
uh and that might have kind of helped
give her some confidence going into the
competition
yeah what was your behind the scenes
like was there something
like i know you can only prep so much to
be on the show and then you get there
and you see how it all
is made and so what was maybe the most
surprising thing to you about the
production side of it
um it was the surprising thing to me
was the fact that which i'm sure you may
have heard this talking to any of the
drag race girls
um that we can't talk to each other
right that's the biggest surprise i'm
sure you know like
it's everything else kind of makes sense
but it really doesn't make sense until
especially being a fan of the show and
watching the show you don't pick up on
the stuff that happens behind the scenes
and so
that uh that's probably the biggest was
the biggest surprise to me is the fact
that they didn't want us
to talk to each other they worked very
hard to make sure that we weren't
communicating with each other
wow and so that was interesting
and for hours we um don't have
we didn't our season we didn't have i
don't know what evie ali had we did not
have
the ability to watch what we wanted
i'm not sure if evie was just watching
cable tv we didn't have television we
had cable tv
but there really wasn't a lot of like
watching going on because
we woke up at like 6 a.m yeah
went to set got home at like 12 or 1 a.m
most nights and then we had to be up at
6 a.m and again like it was like a six
to seven
hour period and a lot of those you know
unless it was like the weekend like our
one day all we had like a day
but sometimes we had two days off um
and that was lovely yeah actually we had
two days off which was
actually agonizing because you're locked
in your hotel room and you can't go
anywhere
and so i'd hear somebody run like a kid
run in the hallway and i'd be like oh
somebody's happy look
to the people to see who's who's
laughing
and i would like you know enjoy whatever
that was
yeah yeah you're just like any sign of
human life that's happening around me
yeah it's joyful let me experience that
yeah how did you keep yourself grounded
through something like that i mean i
know it's probably such a whirlwind that
thinking back to it it's hard to
remember like specific moments but
how did you keep yourself calm
well i'm not sure that i did to be
honest with you i mean i was
i was terrified the whole time and then
after
um you know like after each day
i would immediately start focusing on
whatever the next thing was that i
thought we were going to
do yeah or uh learning my
the words to the lip sync songs right
i just knew that i was going to be
having a lip sync like no matter what
like i was like oh my god girl you're
gonna have to lip sync
even on time even when i won i was like
you're
you better get ready because they're
gonna throw some curveball
twist yeah and it's just and it's gonna
be you and so
that i was constantly like in this sort
of paranoid energy
yeah i mean that's something i guess you
really can't prepare yourself for
uh that there are twists and turns in it
so once you think you have everything
figured out
they can change something on you um
that's so wild and like kudos to your
mental health for getting through all of
that because that seems
unbelievable now since drag race you've
had so many amazing opportunities you've
done so many incredible things
you've done broadway you're doing tv how
how has that whirlwind post the show
been for you
uh it's been great you know i mean it's
certainly
been a dream um like you said a
whirlwind
uh i'm i'm i'm really thankful that i
have the platform that i have
been able to be kind of a part of the
different projects and
um things that i've been able to do it's
been it's been
a dream you know i couldn't be any more
grateful
well let's talk a little bit about
broadway because uh one you got to do
that which
is an amazing amazing thing especially
because you went to a performing arts
high school college high school and
college yeah
okay so this was in your wheelhouse this
is wasn't like
you know they're giving a drag queen an
opportunity to be on broadway like
you're really
like have studied and are ready for this
what was it like because not only were
you on broadway you're originating a
role
on broadway it was hell really it was
absolute hell
yeah i mean i loved it i loved it i
would never take it back
but like originating a role like i guess
to most people oh you're on broadway
it's it's all the same if you're just
there it's
whether you're no matter who you are or
what you do or how you got there
you're there and that's all that matters
but there's a big difference between
like doing a guest like celebrity spot
where you come out and sing a quick song
and you know you don't really have to do
that much rehearsal
and originating a role
um like it was like we got
um copies of the script and they'd be
like okay this is the new song and then
you'd rehearse it
and they'd take and take it out i
remember we we
we were in previews which meant
basically you're previewing it but it's
not officially open
and you're doing rehearsals all day from
nine to five
and then you have a show that night and
then the next day you have another
rehearsal so it's
rehearsal show rehearsal show for a
month wow
horrible that's the first thing um
but then i remember we were in previews
we just finished rehearsal and they were
like oh my gosh
we need to do this new thing we need to
record something
and have it play in the show and so and
they're like
peppermint you have to do it you're the
one who's to do it and so they
got me in a car during my lunch break
you're one moment to yourself to go
down run down to a um recording studio
record the things that they wanted me to
record
and and then come back to get ready for
the show by the time
i got back to the theater
they had to listen to it and decided
they don't want it in the show
wow oh wow
i mean so your patients are tested in so
many ways that's what the whole
experience is like
learning lines that aren't going to be
in there they're like okay
here's the new lines do them tonight and
you and you walk out to the stage and
they're like
oh i know you're about to go on the
scrap those lines do the lines from
three nights ago
go and you're like you know it was hell
it was like that yeah and you have to be
a professional and you have to
like the show most go on and you have to
show the audience that this is like you
got this
and they have nothing to worry about uh
were there any like
uh moments on stage that either
something went wrong
or is it yes
yeah there's a live show there's lots of
those moments but
one of the ones i'll never forget it's
i was uh it was my big my character's
big speech
and everyone was on stage and it was a
big emotional speech and so obviously
the music
was very soft sweet music that was like
supported that and i went to start
delivering my speech
and then that's what was supposed to
happen
and and the the music it's a live
orchestra playing and just playing a
keyboard
um it's an electronic keyboard so she
you know when she wants it to be like
violins and sounding like
soft music she can do that and then she
wants to change it and have other stuff
happening
um and so some i don't know what went
wrong
some button got stuck on the keyboard or
something
and i went to talk and it was like
the disco trumpets from hell
and everyone jumped because it was loud
first of all
it was supposed to be a sweet moment and
it was like and then
i tried to deliver my thing but it kept
it got stuck
and i tried i was like i'm gonna deliver
this soft speech
and but then eventually i was like i
can't look yo i'm an actor but this is
too much
and so i looked around everybody started
laughing and we waited until the thing
fixed because it was
it was like what there were some times
when that when this when the when the
wrong tree
a tree came coming in during the thing
and you're like here's a tree
it's just life wow well i mean and
that's what makes a
live theater so fun is that you really
never know what's going to happen
are there a lot of similarities uh or
are there more differences between
uh performing drag and doing broadway
i think there's a there's a lot of
similarities and those are certainly a
lot of things that i could use to my
advantage when
going to perform on broadway but i think
the biggest difference
was that there is a lot less freedom i
mean
in terms of preparing for the
performance and then obviously doing it
a lot of this stuff you need to be what
they call on the mark which is like you
know
you need to be in your spots at that
moment in time
because not only are the lights going to
come on in that spot
and if you're not there then you're not
in the light but then also there might
be scenery moving through it's all kind
of timed out
dancers are coming through sometimes a
dancer will be moving backwards
and that's how it's choreographed and so
you need to be like
josh the dancer here's the scenery get
in your spot there's the light
it's like that it's like a moving
machinery it's like almost like being on
a conveyor belt
yeah and so um that's different than
most drag performances where you know
i got my outfit and you have my song
i'll do what i want
right spotlight follows me you know yeah
that's true you have to follow the
spotlight there
um now you you've done so much stuff
you've done
posts you've done snl you've done all
these like very wild
incredible things and then this year
happens and
there's a quarantine in place and it's
literally like screeching halt how has
that transition been
for you because i i admire
the entire drag world's ability to adapt
over the last few months it's been
incredibly inspiring to see
how everyone is is doing their gigs in
different ways how has it been for you
it's been the same i mean you know the
beginning of the quarantine probably for
a lot i think
honestly clearly when the pandemic first
hit
in the in the beginning of the year
everyone sort of was like
we were all kind of catatonic and
stunned
um and obviously we needed to take our
time and stay inside and follow the
protocols and so i did that
and new york you know was particularly
hit
yeah very hard and so we were not even
doing half the stuff that other people
in other cities and states were doing
yeah we were like oh we're stuck inside
and we're stuck inside and that's right
um and so that was tough uh
you know a lot of all my gigs i mean i
was planning on
releasing the album touring and doing
shows earlier in the year
and obviously we had to stop all of that
and it wasn't safe and everything
um and so that was tough the first like
month or so i pretty much just sat
inside
and i ate way too many french bread
pizzas
which i hadn't had in years and i forgot
how good french bread pizza
yeah it's it's one of those that you
really have to circle back to
i mean i see nothing wrong about it when
i think about
it me neither i was circling back honey
i would go to that grocery store and get
a box and
and then i like let me get another box
because i know i'm gonna want more of
this
and i couldn't eat just one like i'd eat
a pizza french bread pizza
and then i'd be like you know well that
other one is just alone in the freezer
i might as well heat it up and eat that
one too
and so i did and so that was me and then
i was like sitting around you know like
watching
netflix all of netflix tiger king i know
you know and then i was like oh my god
if the
if the best thing that happens during
this
whole pandemic is tiger king
then i'm gonna explode yeah but
luckily you know i mean not luckily but
then we had the opportunity as you know
to ha get into some
deeper conversations about stuff that
was happening a lot of the problems and
issues that were going on
in 2020 things that we really couldn't
avoid anymore
yeah and i was i felt grateful
that my life was sort of my business
life was sort of on pause
to be able to do um to take place in a
lot of those conversations and we even
had
you mentioned evie oddly we even had
evie oddly on
an event that i did called black queer
town hall and she was a guest
oh very cool well you've always been an
advocate and
you've always used your platform to
speak about
things that are incredibly important and
i think um
things that people hadn't been
comfortable or giving more
space and a platform to talk about and
so i think it's
and now you're doing a lot in terms of
like
uh really encouraging people to vote how
have these conversations like it is kind
of cool to reflect and go oh my life
slowed down so i could have these
conversations in a like very meaningful
way
is that kind of on the forefront because
when you look at your social media when
you look at
um the way you've kind of positioned
yourself right now you're
you're really speaking a really
important messaging right now and i
think that's incredibly cool
have you made that kind of a stronger
mission i know it's always been part of
your world
but like you said does that come to the
forefront for you now
yeah i mean it it has um
and mostly i guess because you know you
can't really have a conversation
alone you know like other people
needs to have to participate in it and
so
there's been a lot more of that like in
the past i remember hearing like from
like folks like bianca del rio used to
always get on me because i was such a
um she would call me like way too nice
and always so serious talking about
these things that like
were important uh pla issues you know
like um aids and hiv or marriage
equality and things like that were
really important to me not that bianca
doesn't care about those things
but i would always bring it into my
stage
performance um in terms of like talking
about it or trying to engage people
in the audience and um lots of queens
used to like
be like oh this one with her speeches
again
but now i think ever many people are
able to make space in their
their person their platform their public
facing
platform their social media whatever to
at least
highlight some of these issues whether
they engage wholeheartedly or not
and so um i'm so i'm grateful that
there's more people interested in having
these conversations and and focusing on
these issues
for you what's the what's the most
important thing for you
talking about now is it is it voting
well i mean this week for sure the issue
is voting um and but it really is
look it's aside from that it's not to
like you know
back up on anything but it really is
kind of all-encompassing i think
the two biggest issues to the three
biggest issues
that really do plague us when it comes
to
discrimination and problems with the
world and the united states
are racism misogyny
and ableism which is you know um
discrimination against basically
discrimination against disabled people
and so i think the one of those three
things is always at play and i think
that they're related
um in some way shape or form they they
you know they trickle down into
everything that we do
um and so we have these systems that are
in place this way of life
these traditions uh in our country and
in the world
uh whether it's employment or voting or
things that are social or
things that are in our family traditions
whatever they are all of those three
things are present at any given time
and and they they are a problem which is
why we keep seeing police brutality
why we keep seeing uh injustices
happening uh
towards women and why there's still a
pay gap why they're still
all that uh you know misogyny and
homophobia and all this discrimination
and so i'm always focused on how we can
address those things
and everything that we do so in voting
how we can not only
pay attention and tell people to vote
but we really need to fix the system
the gerrymandering the the voters id
and voter suppression things like that
that are messing up
the election and every election in the
past present and future
um and so yeah voting is very important
i want people to do it
but it's not just voting for the
president even if you're not
excited about voting for the president
voting for
the people in your city and state and
local who are in charge of your bridges
and your roads and how much money you
make at your job
and what happens with your rent and all
those things that's really important
um also flipping the senate because we
know what just happened with
the the supreme court flipping the
senate if you
are interested in take um
protecting minority groups and
marginalized people and flipping the
senate
in our favor um is is a
is what i'm focused on doing um and so
all of that is connected to voting right
but it's not just vote
whether to vote for trump or biden it's
more than that
um i think that's great what's what's
important to me yeah
yeah and i think because myself included
i think a lot of people can be very
overwhelmed
and sort of like flooded by how
many issues seem to be in flux and not
know exactly where to focus their
attention
to be able to be helpful i think like
you said being able to
to say it's not just voting for a
president it's voting down the ballot
and making sure you're focused on
getting your information for your ballot
and the people that
align with your points of view that help
the larger goal
because that's what i was going to ask i
feel like a lot of people from what i've
noticed online
obviously want to help but then they get
overwhelmed with how do i even begin to
help
and so do you have any advice like where
to start or what to
kind of like centralize your focus on
i'm going to be sharing some um
initiatives to my
platform but i think essentially it's it
it is a lot it is daunting
but i think it's important like just in
terms of the frame of mind
put yourself in the frame of mind that
we know that more than one thing is
happening at once
so let's think personally and globally
at the same time like in this the macro
and the micro at the same time
it's just two different it doesn't need
to be binary but two different things
so when you talk about voting what is
that going to do for my community the
people around me and my city and state
that's the first that you should look at
and then the second thing you should
look at is nationally
how do a lot of these issues that are
national issues
uh how do they connect to the candidates
and what are the research that we're
gonna do
many of those things do come back to
local
like you know gun control is a national
issue
but if you're in your city and state
what's happening with the gun control
laws are you know
are do you agree with them are there
candidates that that you
you know um want to support and so those
things are really important
paying attention to your city and like
um
senate and your uh um house of
representatives like
the city government is like so important
you're voting for the judges
you're voting for the police officers
and the the police captains
um and the commissioner like all of
these people who and
who make the decisions that affect your
life you are voting for
right now and so um and so i know it is
daunting for people that
surely should go to either vote.org or
vote.gov
to get more information about the voting
process
and then once you squared away with the
voting process registered
figure out where your polling place is
find out if anything has changed because
of covid
um make sure that your id is the one
that you need
then you can look more into the
candidates and do your research about
them
just take a very methodical pace to it
but you have to start now you can't wait
until november 3rd
when you wake up to like try to do it
that's when it becomes daunting
yeah and so i like to tell people that
voting ends
november 3rd the election is right now
yeah that's a great way to that's a
really really helpful way
to see it and i think takes a lot of the
uh
overwhelm out of it for for people if
they think about it that way
okay we're going to take a quick break
when we get back uh i have to talk about
the new music
i'm so excited for you so we'll be right
back with more not too deep
hi friends grace helbig here from the
podcast not too deep which you are
currently listening to
hosted by me grace helbig just wanted to
say a couple of things one
thank you so much for listening and two
if you are enjoying yourself to such a
degree that you'd love to leave
us a um review on the apple store
that would be so appreciated because
again you are very appreciated for
giving us your time your ears your
attention
whatever it may be uh and that was my
couple of things
now back to me me
okay peppermint uh a girl like me
letters to my lovers this
is your upcoming music now it had like
you said it had to be put on hold a
little bit
longer than you wanted it to be but what
can you tell us about this because it's
been
what eight or nine years since your last
release of music of original music
that was my first um album it's been
eight or nine years i actually did
release an
ep uh while i was on drag race in 2017.
okay to very little fanfare and so
the whole album went was it platinum
gold no aluminum
so uh so that's that but okay
um but this is the certainly
the first of its kind and probably
forever for me
uh because the other albums previously
were mostly
although i've always had a song or two
that was more sentimental
and things like that that the albums
overall were
mostly drag albums right like really
focus on
the the drag aspect of my life and kind
of that fun
aspect which is great but i really
wanted the opportunity to do something
that
[Music]
last year and spilling into this year um
were just such a life-changing year for
me
life-changing moments for me i was in a
relationship
like you said i'd been on broadway i
just come off of drag race
there's a lot of big moments in my life
that were happening for me personally
um and i think just that the world was
changing in a way that i could just
start to feel
and so i wrote all that stuff down in my
diary and i had one hell of a year
and then i said let me put all of this
stuff to music and so my entire diary
basically
um i mean a year's worth of entries we
put to music
and we had a beginning a middle and an
end and so the beginning is this first
ep
a girl like me letters to my lovers and
then the other ones will come out next
year
wow and so i was in a relationship
i was having a i was enjoying a lot of
being single dating having sex
and then i met someone okay and we
you know we dated and we flirted and we
did that whole thing and and so this
first album
is really that part of the process like
beginning to see each other going on
dates and all that stuff
um and and yeah so it's a very personal
album that i hope people are
have you always kept a diary or did you
just start
in la in the last year because of how
you were feeling
i did exactly i i had not always kept a
dart
honey i don't take i don't keep dying
you generally don't keep retiring i
don't care
i don't write anything down i don't take
a picture
i don't know where that receipt is none
of it but then
i was like you know i'm gonna let me i
had such
i had so much i needed to process and it
wasn't
it was time heals wounds but it was more
than that
yeah because we had become at least for
me so
interwoven me and my ex partner i become
so
interwoven and there was lots of things
moments
um movies you know the normal thing
movies i didn't want to
watch because we had watched them yeah
places we had gone before
dates and moments in time like that that
and that anniversary moment
and there's lots of anniversaries to me
i'm like making up anniversaries like
not the anniversary of us being together
but the anniversary of the last time i
was at that restaurant
was with him and so all of those things
are agonizing
yeah and so i needed to write it down
and i knew that
i wanted to sort through some of these
feelings and just look at them and then
it
it just turns out that of course it
makes sense for to put them to music
you know yeah did you have any
reservations
about putting something so personal out
there
absolutely i've never really done it in
a way i'm a really personal person
um private person and i
generally don't like to be that
vulnerable but it was
obviously what i needed for myself it
was cathartic
and to tell you the truth it was
honestly the first
time considering how
terrible i felt after the breakup um
which you know spoiler alert we
eventually break up even though the
first album is not about that
um uh i was surprised
that i was able to turn all of the
feelings all that pain
all of that agony all that like afraid
to like
turn look on my social media because i
might see something
yeah all of that turned into something
so
beautiful that i am so proud of i can't
even believe
it's the same product but
it is and i feel good about that there
must be some kind of
release and you know you're you're an
extremely confident person
and you you really put on this very
courageous kind of persona that inspires
a lot of people
that to be able to be vulnerable must
feel kind of nice
to like let that side of you out a
little bit
it is nice when people you know
especially
given that people i'm able to hear
people's responses to some of it
i had the chance to do a couple of
previews of some of the music and
oh cool and people seem to respond
really well to it and of course
we're our own worst critic right so i'm
really i'm really tough on myself
um and you know my inner
demon is like you're horrible yeah
of course and so it is nice to be able
to have
um people respond you know in a way
and receive it well did you do you have
like a
group of people or maybe one person that
you send like
previews to that you really value the
feedback on
not not not in that way
it would be great if i was like okay
here like that people that i have that
relationship with
of course just people that i love and
trust and whose opinions i appreciate
yeah i was really secretive about the
whole process
until it was finished
wow until it was ready i'm like okay i'm
premiering it tonight
yeah no one's heard it but
hopefully you'll like it wow that's i
mean that's very very cool
uh what has been if there has been
the most surprising feedback to it
you know um the most surprising feedback
to it is
how uh it hasn't been
i can't say totally surprising um but
how much
people identify with it i mean i knew
that they would when you write about
love and emotions
it's the universal subject right that's
probably the most popular subject for
music
but um hearing people talk about their
experiences
and how they've um been able to
resonate with the with the music and the
lyrics has been great especially people
who don't even identify as queer or
trans
just hearing them say oh i've been
exactly through that like the song
the uh first single that we released
best sex
yeah um it's all about those [ __ ] boys
and
you know being um addicted to them
yeah very relatable yeah
but that's fantastic did you have to
get any sort of permission to release
anything so personal about an ex or did
you just kind of
do your own thing i told him just out of
um heard it like out of just sheer
courtesy
yeah i was going to be writing some
material that ex was
our experiences but i don't use like his
name and like address or number
maybe i should and go get him go get him
i didn't though because i'm a lady yeah
but um so yeah i didn't i don't think i
was
um i'm that deep in but um we did have
to get
music permission because i have a cover
on the album
oh to me to get permission for that
i mean that's the right kind of
permission to get um
what's this so what's the plan you've
had to kind of reschedule the release of
it which
must be frustrating and
crazy but so what's what's the plan now
well the plan was to go out on tour in
the spring
and summer and and i would have been on
the road by now um
and obviously released the album so now
the plan is we released our first
single uh best sex uh at the end of
september
the uh the album comes out on october
16th
and so that's the plan in addition to
that we have all types of juicy stuff
we have the uh music video for best sex
comes out on october 9th
and then um we have a
we were gonna it was kind of an accident
we were gonna shoot a video
a music video and we ended up shooting a
short film whoa cool don't ask me how
that happened
uh and that comes out um at the end of
around halloween
oh that's so exciting and um and like
you said this is a trilogy
right yeah yeah so this it's a trilogy
so part one is now
and then part two and three or later in
our next year
i wanted to take about a year because it
took a year to put together
i'm gonna release it over the course of
a year oh that's so wonderful so people
can
uh know that they have at least a full
year of content from you coming out
that's so exciting
um and now you're also doing pep talks
uh yeah so this is brand new it's brand
new and you're doing this on twitch now
what is this for people that don't know
so uh twitch is an online um
it's like youtube but it's like kind of
right it's like a streaming platform
it's like a streaming platform yeah and
so i have this new show on twitch called
pep talks
it's a rehashing of my um i had a show
on youtube
called pep talks where i would go around
with all the um all of my celebrity
friends
and i would meet up with them or
interview them remotely if we had to
um and just talk and kiki and have a
good old time
and so it's that plus uh
i've been really one of the things i've
been doing which i think a lot of people
been doing is watching a lot of movies
during this pandemic and quarantine and
so i'm
watching movies with my friends um we're
starting with
black movie classics some of the
important black movies that i think a
lot of people haven't seen
yeah um you know uh i think we're in
that mind frame now where people are
like okay
i'm gonna engage in some like black
content and see what's going on
and so i'm inviting a lot of these uh
folks to do it of course many of them
are
drag race queens so our first guest is
alaska where we're gonna watch
uh a raisin and well um actually
our first our first guest was alaska
last week
um and our and our next guest i think is
um is bob the draculine uh great or shea
coulee
see the barber shay i don't remember who
this week but it's every tuesday
at 7 p.m eastern and people just need to
go to my twitch and follow me which is
all the same as my social media
peppermint 247
and tune in and watch the show that's
so you're giving people something to
listen to and something to watch i mean
you're just providing like crazy for
everyone right now
thank you um okay we're gonna take one
last break when we get back i have some
questions from instagram for you
so we'll be right back with more not too
[Music]
deep
[Music]
okay peppermint before we get into these
instagram questions i'm gonna ask you
the two questions i ask every single
guest that is on the podcast
and the first is who alive or dead would
you most like to throw cold spaghetti at
is that like sexual i don't know um
it's pretty it's actually very literal
but i can see how
it could be misinterpreted respecting
everyone's
relationships yes if i could throw
some cold spaghetti at um
and maybe even eat it would be uh jason
momoa
that's a good one i know that i've
gotten that answer before but that's
fantastic
um okay the other question i ask every
single guest is to tell us your worst
pants [ __ ] story
or like a close call bathroom situation
but you can only use
you can only use three words or three
small phrases so
mine is uh college jogging
front lawn wow
okay
[Laughter]
sleepover okay ex-boyfriend
great i feel like if people
get the album they will get more context
to that potential situation
wonderful okay let's jump into a few
questions that came from
instagram uh mandy wants to know what is
your favorite way to do your makeup if
you have one
quickly quickly um favorite way to do my
makeup
yeah you know uh i guess that really is
probably
affected by the products that we use and
by the way
my um mandy you should tune in to
definitely should tune into pep talks
because we'll also be reviewing my
favorite makeup and skincare products
oh wow so there's truly something for
everyone in this
program i would like to think so grace
um but my favorite i guess the way i do
my makeup
like really comes down to what some of
the products
and so my hero product right now which
is going to be a tough one to break
but i'm up for the challenge because i'm
going to be sampling
some new products during this show um
uh is the derma blend
uh flawless creator foundation which is
it's
it's they're billing it as a
pigment a liquid pigment um that's
obviously skin toned
and so that's what i'm wearing right now
it's um
and it's just these drops it's a liquid
foundation essentially but it's like
the strongest liquid foundation you have
ever
really i'm writing it down i love it
flawless creator
trust me one drop will do
two drops two drops let's be real two
drops two okay when i say drops i mean
tear drop like literally itty-bitty
yeah right i don't mean two scoops two
drops will do your whole
face wow i'm trying this
trust me darling i'm like what is this
devil's work yeah okay i have to see
this for myself now
um okay sorry wants to know which queen
would survive the apocalypse
um definitely evie oddly definitely
uh bianca del rio because we can't get
rid of her
um definitely i would say laganja
because she would be in a cave
okay smoking somewhere yeah so those are
my three
pics love it uh
exhausted in every way and trinity
because she's
not even human she's plastic that's true
and plastic is around forever very true
uh exhausted in every way wants to know
how do i find
the confidence
to just the confidence just the
confidence exhausted in every way
i would say that um for me the
confidence comes from
gratitude i i hope that doesn't sound
too trite
but it really is like looking at it
the confidence look the the lack of
confidence is usually for me connected
to
what i think or about other people or
what i think other people think about me
my connection to other people and the
surroundings so in the moments where i'm
having a lack of confidence i'm usually
i what i try to do is just come closer
to myself
and look at what i have what i
contribute my intentions
what i want for the world and other
people and for myself
and what i'm grateful for that i already
have that really does center me
all the time yeah and i think it's one
of those things that might seem so
simple
so people overlook it from time to time
but being able to take that actual
moment
and like you said go in with yourself a
little bit i think that's super
important
um pie friend
wants to know is there anything you
haven't done yet with your drag that you
would really love to do in the future
i mean you're doing so much i'm like
um i would love to be able to
do be comfortable with doing
big like being a drag king doing mail
drag
i think i'd love to try that one day
down the road
cool uh
pipe down wants to know what do you
think is the weirdest drag queen lingo
none of it i love all of it all sounds
very natural to me
is there is there a phrase or anything
that you find yourself using more
than normal lately um you know i'll tell
you the the one that i
was like i missed the boat on uh-huh and
i don't even think i i don't even use it
i might have used it once
is the word shook i i
i was not around when they invented that
for me literally meant is the pat was
the past tense of shaking something
yeah and and so when i and so the first
time i heard it was on drag race
not even from any of the queens some of
the producers and they were asking they
like
i had this they were like using this
word i was like
and they were like well where you shook
and they wanted me to say it and i was
like
i don't even know what it means
yeah and then you're like am i being
pranked into using yeah
what is this word what does it mean
yeah i don't think you missed out on uh
using that word
yeah okay good um carly wants to know
what is the best thing
that you learned about yourself while on
drag race
i think the best thing that i learned
about myself
is that which i it's a lesson that i
keep
learning over and over again is that
i'm perfectly acceptable like warts and
all
not that i have words but you know what
i mean the expression
yeah all of that is acceptable
the the the it's the gritty stuff that
like
is unpolished is what people want
um and so yeah also
you i mean you just in hearing about the
experience you truly prove how resilient
you are
like the amount that you guys have gone
through
is incredible and to do it smiling and
optimistically
and like with such light is is really
wonderful to see um we have we got a ton
of questions
asking all stars question mark
um i would yes yes yes question mark
is my answer to that yes question mark
i love it uh well i hope that that
happens in whatever capacity it could in
the future
um we've reached the end of the podcast
this peppermint but before you go
um usually when we do these in person we
have a personalized fortune cookie as a
gift
to our guests for making time for us but
because we're doing it virtually we have
a virtual fortune cookie
that i believe melissa might have
emailed to you
here it is
peppermint is great for digestion
decreasing bloating and now
music we are still waiting for webmd to
update this list of benefits
however i
love it and i agree yay
um now peppermint where can people find
where you are what you're doing listen
to the music etc
well they can find me just searching for
peppermint on all streaming platforms
for the music that's
uh apple that's itunes that's uh
uh youtube music spotify
all that stuff uh you can find me in my
peppermint 247 on all social platforms
and on twitch every tuesday at 7 p.m for
pep talks
oh that's so exciting because it's live
every tuesday right
it's alive darling so whatever happens
happens
hopefully that keyboard player doesn't
get me
i love it well guys go check out
everything that she's up to
and please listen to the music um and
remember that it's only the first of of
a few more albums and hopefully more and
peppermint thank you again for making
time
thank you see you guys next time on an
episode of not too deep goodbye
too deep too deep too deep not too deep
not too deep is a production of grace
helbig incorporated producer melissa d
montz edited by shireen laniunis post
production sound by chris henry
and an extra special thanks to flula for
the theme music